the commentaries the show where we talk
about the show that you hopefully
already watched on its trailer for
jingle all the way if you stick around
after we talk you'll see some deleted
scenes will respond to comments from
viewers like you
I'm just realizing I forgot to pull any
of them or even look at him so I'll just
go through the comments typical comment
equality tease what the trailer is for
next week Joe London - birthday boys
with me so gracefully yeah yeah you're
ageless I've seen photo evidence I'm
gonna look like this forever I don't
know what to tell you how nice and I'm
50 so jingle all the way Billy's
favorite movie and I think certainly a
fun ride I had a good time it's cruel
it's dark it has a pretty warped view of
but like it's like a cartoon starring
Arnold Schwarzenegger I like that
there's nothing funny in it it's that I
don't like spending time in this world
it's an angry world full of miserable
people who hate Christmas it's a sweaty
passionate capitalist Christmas Jordan
[Laughter]
is nothing more heartwarming than a
man's refusal to realize that he should
change and instead thinks they can just
make it up with one big gesture it's my
favorite genre movie yes usually in that
movie the man has to learn by the end
like oh I can't win my family's love
with one grand guys do the work I gotta
be present in their lives like a person
who cares about them and loves them not
just by like like he doesn't just get
him the toy he becomes the toy yes
commodifies himself he's embracing the
idea of being able to buy someone he
becomes a human Funko puppet man like
whatever you do to achieve your goal is
fine like somebody else was hired to be
turbo man that day that guy is out of a
job on Christmas Eve yeah I mean also I
think we're all committing the sin of
imbuing this movie with maybe more depth
than it was intended but I guess it's a
product of its time talk about movies
sorry sorry we're not allowed to do that
again a cartoon this is a
two-dimensional fun throw park ride like
you could put the roller-coaster things
over your shoulders and then just play
this movie in front of you and like
swing around like a guy frenetically
chasing down a toy and it's like a wily
coyote cartoon without the like there is
satirical stuff in here about like mobs
you know stomping oh stampedes and
stores and like the crassness of the
commercial is like they almost put that
in and then they backed out at the last
minute like I guess someone has to go
back and do their PhD studies with their
PhD because those things won't be found
here LAN it's just it's not there's no
meaning to the mob it's just the pure
joy of watching a lot of people step on
some
just a bunch of good old trampling that
was like that was it wasn't like this
movie predates that screener says he was
inspired by Friday murders to go right
and then this happened to come out the
same years tickle-me-elmo
wow that's really like there is social
relevance they just refuse to like look
directly at it clips I think they start
to realize at a certain point that like
it's still a Christmas movie so they
keep some of that in but it's like we
also know we still want people like it's
you know we're still gonna have the
explosion and it's gonna like do the
old-school cartoony thing where like it
puts up a bunch of ash on someone's face
they realize that those two things can't
mix very well yeah I don't know what
they did believe in isn't super
congruous like it doesn't mix but then
they just upped more of the nut shots or
whatever yeah yeah I actually had to put
the heartwarming scene about Christmas
post corrupt that nut shots per minute
ratios they're they're really clipping
along one it's got a high npm yeah
alright let's watch the Australian for
jingle all the way
[Music]
it's a wonderful life proof that
everyone has value
home alone showed us why we shouldn't
take family for granted but one holiday
bill will teach us Christmas starts
everyone into an epic told jingle all
the way I'd like to just take a moment
to appreciate Arnold's noise based
comments yes I know yeah we did a whole
run of that in Total Recall but I feel
like he's got some really underrated
noises thing is that they're all the
same
Arnold noises based on the same things
like he gets hit in the face here oh but
like this time it's supposed to be funny
and not just the way we laugh at it
I apologize if we made this exact same
joke already but I always just think
about him doing ADR for his own choices
like the Hugh Jackman wondering doing
that stuff but just Arnold going it's
great in this because it really
highlights we make a joke about how it's
so weird that he's this Austrian
bodybuilder in American Minnesota
suburbia and it's like never mentioned
that many the only time they've
addressed that is Terminator 3 delete
this one it's great because it really
highlights how like we're out of places
character is like I'd like a typical
suburban dead stuff again stolen was
this written for someone else it must've
been wonder yeah in Minneapolis
you know Schwarzenegger give you the
name Howard leg stroke I don't think you
ever writers like this guy students like
Howard yeah I know the bad part I was
gonna get to this later was written for
Joe Pesci originally yeah yeah
it seemed like more Pesce energy than
Joe Pesci would steal a child in front
of a crowd with Pesci playing Myron you
get more it's more like just criminality
rather than insanity like the wait just
really feels like I was really thinking
during the movie we were gonna get that
Planes Trains twist at the end and he
doesn't even have a son he's not even
he's literally just stealing toys for
like something to do and like Schwartz
is gonna have to invite him to lie to
their home like it almost seems like
it's coming cuz he's such a maniacal
crazy person just a crazy person
yeah he's talented mr. Ripley Arnold or
something like that yeah you think like
there's got to be some other layers like
nope just a dad who wants a toy and he's
just insane whereas I think with Pesci
it would have been more like this guy is
just he's like no morals and he's gonna
do what he has to do it was to prison
for life because he didn't want it
better
he's like bombing places it's pretty bad
pause they're ready for Schwarzenegger
Carboni don't worry it has just as much
violence as other stuff you know aren't
like your ordinary Austrian bodybuilder
mattress game bins my number one
customer you're my number one customer
you're my number one customer witness
neglected son Christmas Howard will
place a one-minute rail construction
Tobias gets loved by any means necessary
whether that means lying to his wife's
face I got the Tillerman doll grabbing a
child by the face or punching an animal
kid the things you started it
not all movies need to be or deserve you
know the the treatment of three
dimensions this is a very where of
reindeer do anything sure yeah that's
not saying yeah it's fine also because
it gives that reindeer beer at the
wasted there's like the scene where you
see them drinking him in the reindeers
like passed out and I would think we get
another if you hurt an animal then
getting them drunk is not making it up
to that animal that's that's hurting
them more brother nature would not be
away from today's show it's also the
plot of the upcoming Doolittle he really
commits to the New Zealand oh wow yeah
I'm excited more than that alright let's
get going
hey a heart or slaughterfest watch a bad
- to find a limited release toy in a
world without smartphones or eBay where
you were constantly forced to interact
with other people
like the only other global star on our
knees level in 96 Sinbad
he'll play the rival sociopath Myron an
alcoholic mailman who has so many
assaults kidnappings and felonies by the
end of this thing you just know it'll be
his last Christmas as a free bad Merry
Christmas
sorry kid that's going to the evidence
Locker maybe one of the cops has a son
who ate some too so pause we didn't get
to really talk about it but I feel like
most of sin beds dialogue in this film
the writer just wrote Sinbad does
someone who has had a knee Mia before
and had to explain to people like no
it's not the black people kind but yes
he's just he just rips and you think
that like it must have just been so
funny on the day of shooting but they're
like oh we can't cut any of this is gold
in my heart also on set Arnold would try
to riff back and be like I think he knew
enough to just smile and nod because he
didn't understand half of what Sinbad
yeah it's weird how much they let Sinbad
go he's the only one bringing that
energy this movie everybody else is like
it seems it's outrageous it's big with
its it's scripted it's good and then
they're all like I'm gonna come in and
do my part and then it just simply just
goes like he's introduced with a
90-second just ran nothing in particular
it was clearly an extra because he has
no idea what to do I guess a person also
wouldn't know but nobody else is
reacting cuz they're like we're honest
in bed said they're like look he might
grab process I know doesn't know what
he's talking about unless you were alive
during that period you also have never
it was all very specific I mean cuz he's
like he was a B was a stand-up comic so
he was writing all of his like you know
his trailer on the gigolo he's reading
the paper like looking for what he's
gonna riff about in the magazine yeah
all right man let's let's keep watching
any redeeming characters in this movie
know his wife is a nagging cliche where
are you what's his soul it's plowing his
way through every mom in the
neighborhood pause we didn't really get
to talk about fill harbor in this movie
he's fantastic he's really funny
you can't you Scrooge can't even deny
that it's a very very OneNote it's not
that fun no there's layers to him not a
terrible joke but it's just that one
joke over and over again
yeah he's very smart choice yeah but the
fact that like he didn't do it until
after the divorce is like a weird thing
then like he when he snaps a couple
times there's some real darkness going
on there like when he screams at the
kids as soon as funny performance I
think Phil Herman is getting everything
you could get out of this very OneNote
so his wife left him
it sounded like what his kid was talking
it's like he was also like Howard and
not paying attention and then all of a
sudden started being this lake neighbor
banging good guy right there like paying
attention to his kids and all this stuff
I also like I'm not a real big innocent
rustic so this movie's like not speaking
a whole lot to me like this is not for
me Oh like goofs are hijinks I like
goose in high jinks I just don't like
it's a little too slapstick II for me
but I like Phil Hartman in it yeah yeah
yeah he's good yeah
I don't know I until they do it baby
they do a backstory thing with with Phil
Hartman in this where the rom-com guy
they were like yeah suddenly we have to
make the other guy immediately just the
dirt worse right because look single guy
working through the subdivision you know
maybe not my cup of tea because he
burned his hand the funnier take on
civilians it's like in the beginning you
think they're doing a Flanders thing
which is that his neighbor's nice and
just like Schwartz acres not nice and
that's why he hates him like this guy
who's constantly showing him up and
making him look Bay which is funnier
than that guy being a sleaze and it's
funnier for him to go and eat his wife
doesn't think Howard is bad definitely
think is on the Howard is bad train the
very end of the film it comes that one
can only hope is a satire of
commercialism because it spends 80
minutes of showing you the dark
malevolent forces of capitalism turning
us into beasts and exactly one minute
reminding us that family was the true
gift all along huh
maybe they expand on this in the sequel
kill it kill away fire they do nothing
Sinbad in this movie hi I'm Phil Hartman
you may remember me from such films as
sergeant bilko Sunday weapon one and
Amazon women on the moon The Phantom
Menace ok booster we decided to layoff
Jake Lloyd because first of all he's a
child he's a child and he stopped
it's just acting performance and he's
suffered enough we've been enough to
have done it this movie's a good example
of how he is like was a very typical
child and like people are so like the
issue with fandom Ennis is not the Jake
Lloyd performance phantomon yes yeah
exactly so there you go good direction
he was just like every other kid actor
out there right there yeah an angel all
right perfect
I'm getting the hang of so glad that he
make Iron Man in the 90s we're working
on with Tom Cruise yeah it was always
like one of those things every few years
that was sort of being thrown out yeah
but The Rocketeer - I just recently
watch that great movie but that is also
what the flying around scenes look like
[Music]
for a Christmas parade they built a
fully functional turbo man yeah yeah is
a entertainment parade you'll find out
how they built it when we do fandom I
Arella whatever man was real turbo
versus army who could like fly The
Strongest Man
yeah all right let's watch some deleted
scenes bring the kids what do you think
it's time to ruin Christmas for them
toxic male school entity The Postman
Always Rings Twice the Postal Service
seemed literally going postal boy
Christmas daddy's boy jiminy chill
occurs a youngling saving this is hey
it's me
Bellucci the crypt of the magic
Christmas Colonel Mustard car revenge of
the booger oh man wait isn't that the
voice of two peas from Batman the
Animated Series
[Music]
commit felonies hmm there must be
something about you he doesn't like
streaming about dogs we use them to
spawn terminators where's your Christmas
spirit it's a long way around for that
stupid pacing from the Terminator movie
[Laughter]
we could remake movies so they'd work
better for us true yeah that's true yes
someday someday it's um it's bull from
Night Court is the guy who's the voice
from two-faced and also the brain guy
right I don't know John Bailey said he
knew him yeah I'm almost positive well
they're even right yeah more famous is
the bailiff from Night Court than the
voice of to face from a certain place
yeah I actually never ended up looking
up any fan questions or comments so Joe
asked a question and Lana and Danielle
will answer it while I look those up
well sounds good
what are you guys doing for Christmas
I'm actually probably gonna stay in the
city because I really like
let's get back to Phil Hartman's
character sure eyes
what's he really I mean obviously when
he gets a little it gets to aggro like
the Turnbull aggro alright I got some
really only at the end he goes too far
seem in the car cause everybody is
obsessed with the line put the cookie
down why why that line over all the
others boo Billy's staying out to you
guys Billy why is that line so funny
it's a a lot of Schwarzenegger lines
that have become memorable it's the he's
too intense for the rest of the scenario
around him which is the same as it's not
a tumor and I think that's the that's
what people are ready to hear him with
his accent say the phrase that's
baseline but I think it's also like the
kid like he could be a tumor like the
kids aren't fired up he gets really
fired up and it's the same where he's
just like Phil Armas just enjoying a
cookie and then his reaction is so
over-the-top angry I think that's where
that's why it's funny also it's meat sex
with his wife
and also double entendre so people
saying I feel really bad for Jake Lloyd
didn't deserve the hate he got fun fact
he's the younger brother of Danny Lloyd
from The Shining that the child actor
from The Shining is that true I think no
age wise that would still they'd be
twenty years apart I'm starting to doubt
whether chief Schneider Scheider
on YouTube knows what he's talking
let me see we're gonna figure this out
right now oh this is gonna be gripping
content you guys yeah yeah sorry we
didn't still talk yeah I don't think
that's true just because the ages they
would be names wonder if this whole mix
it's alright that's it you guys didn't
really have many questions in the
comments so just a bunch of requests for
John to say I'm not a pervert and also
good and Samantha my question is why
does the turbo man Show look so much
like Power Rangers but it's not like
it's translated from Japan it's just
like we made our own Power Rangers
because I think it yes is my answer I
think they were like oh that's the thing
try we tried to make a bunch of
different Power Rangers Samurai
cybersquad big bad beetleborgs ubers to
be our troopers we if you were gonna
make if you were making this movie and
you were gonna make a parody of the
Power Rangers we might be the thing
you'd make fun of the thing that
everybody knows about it's fun I mean if
you were making like a great movie also
maybe you don't want to make fun of like
the Japan miss the show
there's even seen where Sinbad puts
chopsticks up there you go I'll be
better prepared next week I'm already on
Christmas vacation which I'll spend in
my room you come back next week where
we'll be doing the honest trailer
commentary for next week's film which
will be spooky but also funny depending
on how you look at it Devan what you
find humorous okay not many people do
but I did so we'll see the two next time
thanks for watching nostril
[Laughter]
you